The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Today we're
going to talk about dynamic
storage allocation, which is a
hugely rich and interesting
topic, and hopefully cover some
of the basics of dynamic
storage allocation today.
I want to start out with perhaps
the simplest storage
allocation scheme, and that's
stack allocation, which I
think you're probably fairly
familiar with.
So stack allocation is just an
array and a pointer into the
array, an index or a pointer
into the array.
And when you have a stack in
a computer memory, you're
talking about the array of all
memory, and the stack pointer
pointing that's used, for
example, for calls.
The reason stack allocation
is neat is
because it's so simple.
If I want to allocate x bytes,
then what I do, is I just
simply increment my stack
pointer by x bytes, and then I
return the original position of
the stack pointer as being
the location of the storage
that's just been allocated.
So pretty simple.
Typically if you write a stack
allocator, the routines are so
simple they get inlined,
although it's of course
advantageous to say that things
are inlined, but most
compilers these days
will inline.
And as you can see, it's just a
couple of operations here to
perform this calculation.
To deallocate the bytes,
we basically--
oh, yeah, I should mention,
this isn't
checking for overflow.
So technically, one should
check for overflow.
One way to do that is for the
assert package, and that way,
at run time, you don't
have to pay the
extra overhead of checking.
And see, these operations are
so cheap that actually
checking for overflow is perhaps
as expensive as doing
the rest of the operations
themselves.
Checking to see whether you went
over the right end of the
array here.
So to free x bytes, you
basically just simply
decrement the stack pointer.
And of course, technically,
you should also check for
underflow, make sure somebody
didn't say to deallocate more
bytes than were actually
already
allocated on the stack.
And so course, check for
stack underflow.
So this is pretty good, because
allocating and freeing
take just constant time.
Very quick.
But you're required to free
memory consistent with the
stack discipline, which is the
last in, first out discipline.
So you don't get to free
something that you allocated
long ago until you've freed
everything else that's been
allocated since.
So therefore, it has limited
applicability, but it's great
when it works.
Now it turns out, sometimes you
can actually use the call
stack yourself to store stack
values, using a function
called alloca.
But this function is now
deprecated, meaning that
people advise you not to use it
in any modern programming.
And part of the reason is that
the compiler is more efficient
with fixed size stack frames.
You remember when we went
through how the compiler
actually lays out memory and
does the calling convention?
If you have a fixed size stack
frame, then the frame pointer
and the stack pointer are
redundant, and so you can
reclaim a register, namely, the
frame pointer register,
and do everything off
the stack pointer.
But if you use things like
alloca, which are pushing the
sides of the stack frame, then
you actually have to keep both
pointers there, and that's a
little bit less efficient in
terms of the register usage.
OK?
So that's pretty much
stack storage.
Any questions about stacks?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
that detects overflow or
underflow without
using inserts?
Like, if you wanted to check--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, you
couldn't check explicitly.
Just say, you know, for this, is
before you check that, make
sure that SP plus x, is it
bigger than the right end?
AUDIENCE: But how do you know
where the right end is?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Well, because
I'm assuming here that
in this case, you are
allocating it.
Now, if you're talking
about using the
call stack, you mean?
You'll never run out.
We'll do that analysis
in a little bit.
But you'll never run
out of stack space.
Although as a practical matter,
most compilers assume
a stack of a megabyte, and so
if you overflow that, your
program will fail in any
of a variety of ways.
AUDIENCE: You can
do guard pages.
CHARLES LEISERSON: You can do
guard pages, which don't
always work.
But let me explain
guard pages, OK?
So what's sometimes done is,
if I have my stack growing
down in memory--
OK, so here's my stack, and
it's growing this way--
and I want to make sure, for
example, the thing that's
typically growing up this way
is heat, and I want to make
sure that they don't collide
somewhere in here.
So one thing I can do
is put some pages in
here that are protected.
These are read-only pages.
Or actually even better
is no permissions.
So I can put no permissions so
that if you ever try to read
or write that page, it
automatically generates a fault.
And so the runtime will
sometimes do that.
The difficulty is, what happens
if you increased your
stack so much that you went
beyond your guard pages?
But as a practical matter most
of the times that people
exceed the guard pages is
only by small amount.
And so just putting a few guard
pages in there will make
sure that you can use the memory
management hardware,
which basically ends up being
free from your point of view
as a programmer, in
order to catch a
stack overflow problem.
And you can do that yourself.
You can use the call mmap, which
we haven't talked about,
to set permissions on
pages at user level.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: No.
You can actually handle the
error however you want.
You can vector into a user
to find routine.
Now, what are you going to do,
I don't know, but you can
indeed catch the error yourself
and decide that
there's some way of recovering,
as opposed to
crashing and burning.
So generally, it's considered
poor form for your software to
fail, other than in
a controlled way.
So you should always have your
software exiting or calling
error, and it should never
segment fault.
Most people consider any program
that segfaults to be
poorly engineered.
Is there any case where there's
a segfaulting program
that is not poorly engineered?
I don't know.
I think most people, it's
probably an understatement.
OK?
So this is stack memory.
You can build it yourself out of
an array and a pointer, or
you can I use this
the call stack.
And when you have something
that's using that kind of
discipline, it's great, because
it's really cheap.
Now in C and C++, and we're
going to start moving and
talking more about things like
C++, we have what's called
heap allocation.
And in C, the routines are
called malloc and free, and
C++ provides a new directive
and delete.
So unlike Java and
Python, C and C++
provide no garbage collector.
So in other words, you're
responsible as a programmer
for freeing allocated
storage yourself.
If you fail to do so, you
create a memory leak.
So a memory leak means I
allocated something, I no
longer am in a position to use
it, but I failed to free it,
so it can't be reused.
And if you keep doing that,
especially if you're in a
loop, then you have
a memory leak.
Where if you look at a program
with a memory leak, and you
look using [? Top ?] or
whatever, how big is my
program, you watch as it goes
and computes and computes, and
it keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger
as it's running, and it just
runs away, getting more and
more storage.
Also you have to watch out for
things like dangling pointers.
That is, you deallocated
something, but somebody still
wanted to use it.
Or double-freeing.
You have two places in
the code where you
free the same storage.
Very bad to try to free
the same storage.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's
basically going to be sitting
in the storage structure, which
we'll talk about how
those are organized
in a few minutes--
going to be sitting in the
storage structure, but the
program that is going to look at
that and not recognize that
it's in the storage structure,
and think that it's something
that now all its pointers
can be reset.
And so you basically clobber
all the invariants of the
storage structure, and somewhere
down the road, you
get a segment fault
or something.
OK?
Yeah, John?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that comes out of that is--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Just a second.
Why don't you take this?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
One thing that often happens in
the real world is when you
free something, it adds it to
a free, list and if you free
something twice, it will add two
copies of that pointer to
the free list.
So later on, when you malloc,
malloc might return the same
pointer to you twice.
So the same memory block might
be allocated for two
completely different
functionalities, and attackers
use that to do all sorts
of interesting
things to your program.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
OK?
So fortunately, there are some
really good-- why don't you
keep that down there, and then
if you guys want to chime in,
you'll have some
power to do so.
So fortunately, there are now
some tools to make that easier
to debug these kinds of
really nasty bugs.
The one we'll be using is
Valgrind, and what you do is
you just say, Valgrind minus
minus leak check equals yes,
and then run your program the
way you would normally run it.
And what it will do is, it will
monitor the way that the
program is doing allocations
and frees, and give you a
report as to whether everything
that was allocated
was free, and whether you tried
to free something twice,
and so forth.
Now, this works with the
existing allocators.
If you have your own allocator
that you decide you're going
to write for a little piece of
your code, you say, gee, I'm
going to do my own little
allocation here, you can
actually communicate to Valgrind
what that allocator
is, and it can check for
proper use of that
structure as well.
So you can see valgrind.org
for details.
And are a lot of other programs
on the market, and
out there as open software,
such as purify and
a variety of others.
So let's talk about
heap allocation.
I want to start by talking about
fixed size allocation.
So suppose the world has only
one size of objects that you
care about.
Then it turns out that doing an
allocator is really simple,
and you could program
one yourself.
So here's basically
how it works.
It's called using a free list.
And what you have is, in your
array, say, that you're using
for storing all of your values,
and here they're
basically this size, what you
do is you have a certain
number that are used.
That means that the program
is using them,
not the storage allocator.
And what you do is you take
advantage of the fact that if
it's an unused block of storage,
then you can put a
pointer in there.
And so what you do, is you
string all these unblocked
pieces of storage together
into a free list.
So we point to there, which
points to there, which points
to there, which points to there,
which points nowhere.
So you just simply linked
together all of the things
that are free in that list.
And then whenever you need one
to allocate an object, what
you do is, you grab one
off the free list.
So you set the value that you're
going to want to take
off free list to free--
so here x gets a pointer to this
object, the one that's at
the start of the list.
Then you update free with
free arrow next, which
gives you this guy.
So that's the next
guy in line.
And then you basically
return x.
And that's all there is to it.
You just grab the first element
off the free list.
Now, there's a little bit of
subtlety in that the thing
that you're grabbing off has a
garbage pointer in it, because
we're not initializing
storage.
There are some storage
allocators that will always
set the value that's returned
to the user to
all zeros, for example.
But typically malloc
doesn't do that.
It basically leaves that as
uninitialized storage.
And so you can actually go and
see, what were the values that
used to be stored in there?
And so basically, you can end
up with a garbage pointer
there, but you really don't care
about that, because it's
no longer on the list.
So you can see, for example,
if I then went and I--
well, let's do this, to take a
look at what happens when a
free an item.
So if I want to free an object
x, I take some object x here.
Let's say it's this guy
that's being freed.
What I do is, I make it
point to the first
element of the list.
So basically, next equals
free, So he
basically points there.
And then I say free equals x,
meaning move the free pointer
up to now point to the new
beginning of the list.
So we're basically pushing and
popping things off the front
of the list.
It's just the stack discipline,
except we're using
a linked list, rather
than using an array.
So we push to free, and
we pop to allocate.
Now the tricky thing here--
you can sort of see what might
go wrong if I then said, oh,
let me free this thing again.
Suppose you said, now that this
is free, suppose you came
in and say, oh, I'll free
that thing again.
Well, now you're going to go
through the same code here,
and you're going to see, you're
going to completely
screw up the free list.
So that's why you don't want
to do a double free.
So you can see exactly what's
going to go on in the free
list implementation.
So this is pretty good
and pretty cheap.
Allocating and freeing
take constant time.
That's great, just as
with stack pointer.
It's got good temporal locality,
and the reason is
because you're tending to
allocate the thing that you
freed most recently.
The free list operates
as a last in,
first out data structure.
So from a temporal locality
point of view,
it's really very good.
You're always using the most
recently freed stuff whenever
you allocate, and that means
you have very good caching
behavior from a temporal
locality point of view.
However, it has poor spatial
locality, and the reason is
due to what's called external
fragmentation, where you get
your storage distributed
across virtual memory.
So if you think about this, as
you start allocating and
freeing in different orders,
the order of that free list
gets very jumbled up.
And as it increases, and you end
up with jumping from one
thing to another, you basically
can end up causing
you to use a lot of the page
table, because you're
basically using a huge piece
of it, rather than-- and in
particular, the translation
look aside buffer
can also be a problem.
So the translation look aside
buffer typically works on a
page basis.
And if you recently referenced
things on a given page, that's
very good for the TLB, because
it's already got the
translation, the virtual address
mapping of that page
dealt with.
So it basically has poor spatial
locality, because it's
getting all jumbled up.
Compared to stack allocation,
which is always very nice in
terms of its behavior, because
you're going across
consecutive locations in memory,
which means you're
always allocating and freeing
from the same page, unless you
trip over a page boundary.
So here's some ways of
mitigating external
fragmentation.
Of course, this makes the
code for free list more
complicated.
And then you have to weigh, how
much am I losing in having
a more complicated allocator
versus suffering the
fragmentation may occur?
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: You specificed before
that it was fixed size.
Is that why we don't specify
anything about the size?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
That's right.
We're just assuming that it's
all whatever the unit size is.
So this is really good when
you've created your own data
structure, and let's say you're
doing nodes in a graph.
You know exactly what elements
you want in the graph, for
each vertex.
And now what you want to do is
basically be able to give
yourself a note of a graph, free
a note of a graph, and
manage that storage yourself.
Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
allocated across virtual
memory [INAUDIBLE] one
application?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Why is it
allocated across virtual
memory if it's all
one application?
Well, because the size that you
may end up needing can end
up being large.
And I'll show you in just a
minute how that happens.
So here's the idea.
What you can do is keep a
free list per disk page.
So disk page, a traditional
page is 4,000 bytes.
These days they talk about
super pages that are
megabytes, and who knows what
size pages various operating
systems will support.
I believe the clouds use 4k,
as configured right now are
using 4k, which leads to some
strange anomalies where the
TLB can address less stuff
than the L3 cache.
But so be it.
So basically, they just keep a
free list per disk page, and
basically always allocate from
the free list for the page
that's fullest, the page that
you've allocated the most of
the stuff off of.
Rather than for a page
that's less empty.
So what this means is that when
you come to allocate, you
have to figure out, which
page should I do the
allocation off of?
But we'll have a free
list on each page.
Whenever you free of a block of
storage, you have to free
it to the page on which
the block resides.
Don't put into a free list
of a different page.
You put it into a free list all
of that particular page.
Now if a page becomes empty, in
other words, there's only
the free list on it, there's no
actually used elements by
the programmer, the virtual
memory system
will page it out.
And since the programmer's never
referencing things on
that page, it basically
costs you nothing.
You end up not having to have
an entry in the TLB, and you
may have written to it, but
you will end up allocating
things preferentially to
the more full pages.
And the basic idea is, it's
better to have the use of your
pages balance 90/10
than 50/50.
So this kind [? of fig ?]
configuration
is better than that.
So why is that?
If you have 90% of your storage
on one page and only
10% on another--
yeah, let's say we only of two
pages in our system, and 90%
of the objects are on one page,
and 10% of the objects
are on the other page, versus
if they're 50-50.
Then what you can do is look
at the probability that two
accesses are going to
go to the same page.
Because if you're going to the
same page, then your paging
hardware, which is very much
like the cache, your TLB,
which is very much
like a cache--
whenever you get a hit on the
same page, that's good, it
costs you nothing.
If you hit on a different
page, that's bad.
So what happens is, the
probability that two hit the
same page is, well, for the
first one, it's, what's the
probability that the first
one was on this page,
versus on the other?
So it's going to be on the same
page if they're both on
this page or they're
both on this page.
And so that's going to be 0.9
times 0.9 plus 0.1 times 0.1.
Whereas if it's 50/50, then the
probability that you get
hit on the same page is now this
0.5 times 0.5 plus 0.5
times 0.5, which is only 50%.
So we get 82% hit rate versus
the 50% hit rate.
So it's much more likely, if I'm
stacking everything out in
the extreme, it's better to have
everything on one page
and nothing on the other.
Then I get 100% hit rate,
because whenever I'm accessing
something, I always am hitting
on the page I had before.
So this kind of heuristic
helps it so that you're
swinging your accesses to using
fewer pages, and the
fewer pages, the less likely
it is that you're going to
stress your virtual memory
paging, disk swapping, you're
going to stress your TLB
and what have you.
Good for that?
We're going to get deeper
into this, so.
So that's basically fixed
size allocation.
It's really nice, because you
can basically use a very
simple free list.
But of course what most people
need and want is variable
sized allocation.
The most popular way of doing
variable sized allocation is a
scheme called binned free lists,
and of that, then there
are a zillion variations
on it.
But mostly, people use
binned free lists.
The idea is, we're going to
leverage the efficiency of
normal free lists.
Normal free lists I can allocate
and free in just one
operation, in just a constant
amount of time I make.
And what we're going to do
is accept some internal
fragmentation.
So by internal fragmentation
I mean the following.
When somebody asks for something
of a given size,
what we're going to do is
actually give them something
which is a little bit
bigger, maybe.
And so we'll waste some.
And in particular, what we'll
do is, we'll organize our
system so that all the blocks
that we ever give out are
always a size the
power of two.
In practice, you don't always
give out exactly a power of
two, because then you get cache
alignment problems.
But this is the basic scheme,
is to give out things are
powers of two.
And that way, if somebody asks
for something that has 13
bytes, you give them 16 bytes.
For somebody who asked
for 65 bytes, have to
give them 128 bytes.
So you might waste up to as
much as a factor of two.
But now, for a given that range
of values, there's only
a logarithmic number of
different sizes that we have
to give out, because we're
only giving them out
in powers of two.
So here's the basic allocation
scheme to allocate x bytes.
So what I do is, if I'm
allocating x bytes, what I do
is, I look in the bin ceiling of
log x, because that's where
everything of size two to the
ceiling of log x is, which is
basically rounding x up to
the next power of two.
If it's non-empty, I just return
a block as if it were
an ordinary free list.
And what I'll be doing is
returning a block which is at
most twice the size of
the requested block.
But that's generally OK.
Somebody wants at least
that many bytes.
The fact that it's a few more
bytes won't matter to them.
They don't know that there's
more bytes hidden there.
They only take advantage of the
fact that there are many
bytes as I've asked for.
Otherwise, suppose that
that bin is empty.
There's nothing in that
bin at this time.
Well, then what you do is you
start looking to find a block
in the next larger non-empty
bin, and you split it up.
So for example here,
suppose that the
request is x equals 3.
I have to look in bin 2, which
is blocks of size 4.
Uh oh, bin 2 is empty.
So what I do is, I start going
down, looking in the next bin.
Oops, that's empty too,
that's empty--
and then finally, I get to one
where there is a block in it.
So what I do then is
I dice this up.
I cut it in half, and then cut
that one in half, until I get
a piece that's exactly the
size I want to return.
OK?
And then I distribute all of
these guys up to the other
bins, like this.
So I return one of this size,
and I populate these other
guys with one block each of
the appropriate size.
And as you can see, they're
basically growing in a
geometric fashion.
And then I distribute
that bin.
Now there's a caveat here.
Suppose that no larger blocks
exist in my storage structure.
Well, then I have to ask the
operating system for more
bytes, to allocate x more
bytes of virtual memory.
Now in practice what you do is
you don't actually ask for x,
since you never ask
the operating
system for small values.
You always ask the operating
system for big values.
Give me another page worth,
or give me another
five pages, or something.
Because that's an expensive call
to the operating system,
to ask it to allocate
more storage.
Let me explain how that works.
And this gets back to the
question you had before, which
is, where's the stuff
coming from anyway?
What the operating system is
allocating is actually not
physical pages, but rather
parts of virtual memory.
So we looked at this before,
about how virtual memory is
laid out for a typical
program.
So what we do is, on the very
high addresses, we have the
stack, and the stack
grows downwards.
This is the call stack.
At the low address, we typically
start out with
what's called the text segment,
which holds your code.
Then there's a region called
the data segment, and this
consists of data that needs
to be initialized.
So the compiler typically
distinguishes between data
that needs initialization and
data which is going to be
zero, because data that needs
initialization, it writes into
the binary executable file
and stores that on disk.
So when you load in your
program, it just loads as part
of the text here, it loads that
data segment, saying what
all of the storage is.
The next segment is, for
historical reasons, called the
BSS segment.
And what BSS consists of is all
the variables that at the
start of the program should
be initialized to 0.
It doesn't bother storing
these in the file.
Why not?
Because it's easy enough to just
bring it in, understand
what that distance there is, and
then do a memset of this
whole region with zero, to
zero it out, rather than
trying to read in a whole
bunch of zeroes.
An obvious kind of
data compression.
Then heap storage is allocated
in the space
above the BSS segment.
So the idea is, there's a part
of heap which has already been
allocated stuff.
And whenever you need more
heap storage, you ask the
operating system-- the operating
system moves just as
if it were a stack, moves the
line for where heap is to
allocate, to give you more pages
of heap storage that you
can now allocate out of.
And what it's doing
is allocating
pieces of virtual memory.
Now, here's a good mind
question, which I think gets
directly to your point.
So think about this.
We have a 64-bit
address space.
If I try to write at the rate of
4 billion bytes per second,
that's pretty fast, because
that's the speed at which the
registers get written.
Not the speed that memory
gets written.
So really, it's something like
4 billion bytes per second.
It takes over a century to write
all of virtual memory.
So as a practical matter,
that means I never run
out of stack space.
I never run out of heap space.
They're never going to cross,
no matter how much I'm
allocating.
Even if I allocate on every
cycle, there's not going to be
a program-- unless you're going
to set a program running
for a millennium sort
of thing, you're not
going to see that.
Most programs run for
a few minutes.
Some may run for days.
Some may run for years.
Very few do people write
to run for a century.
So why not just allocate out
of free virtual memory and
never bother freeing?
Why am I worried about freeing
stuff all the time?
Why not just allocate it?
It's virtual memory.
It's virtual.
I just allocate more storage
as I need it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] memory?
CHARLES LEISERSON: So it is
tied to real memory, and
that's part of the answer.
It is tied to real memory,
because anything that you
write must find itself
a place on disk.
Because it's going to be written
to pages, and those
pages are going to be paged
and then written to what's
called the swap space on
disk, which allows you
to put things there.
Even so, though, writing
to disk--
it's still not going
to take very long.
I mean, you're never going to
be able to use up disk,
because disk takes so
long to write for.
But that is part
of the answer.
AUDIENCE: So you need to
basically use [INAUDIBLE]
software?
And so--
CHARLES LEISERSON: And
the page table.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on the disk.
CHARLES LEISERSON: So the issue
is, this is where the
external fragmentation
would be horrendous.
If you just kept writing across
memory, and you only
had a couple of words written
on every page that were
actually used, the rest is just
garbage, then what you're
saying is that in order to
access a given datum, I'm not
going to have it in memory with
it a lot of other stuff.
What I'm going to have in memory
with it is going to be
all garbage, this stuff that
I would have freed.
And so therefore, you end
up having your program
distributed across a large
region of virtual memory, and
that means as we're doing the
paging, et cetera, we're
getting very poor
page locality as
I'm accessing things.
And so I have a finite number of
pages that I fit in memory,
and now I may be blowing that
out, and every access, rather
than going to something
nearby, is
instead going to disk.
And so that can cause disk
thrashing, where every access
causes a disk access.
So how fast are disk accesses?
Order of magnitude?
How fast are disk accesses?
What's a disk access cost?
Fast disk?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: No, it's
slower than that.
Disk access.
So good memory access, DRAM
memory is, like, 60
nanoseconds for DRAM access.
It's like 60 nanoseconds.
So the processor is going
somewhere around, these days,
between 3 and 4 gigahertz.
So memory is like 200 processor
cycles away.
How fast is disk?
An ordinary disk, not a
solid state device.
Ordinary disk.
10 milliseconds is a good
ballpark to give.
That's a good number to know.
10 milliseconds, not 10
microseconds, not 10
nanoseconds.
10 milliseconds.
So you are, what?
6 to 7 orders of magnitude
slower if you go to disk.
Really slow.
So one of the things in
performance optimization--
we're focusing a lot
on the CPU--
is often the case for
database things.
How do you minimize those
disk accesses?
And all the things that we're
learning about, performance
for CPUs, can be applied to
disk accesses, as well.
So the idea here is
we want to avoid--
that's why we don't want to have
our stuff strewn across a
whole bunch of pages where we
only have a fixed amount of
internal memory, because
then we'll end up
paging all the time.
Every access will cause us to
do a disk access, because it
won't be very likely
that we're getting
stuff on the same page.
So getting back, for example,
to the fixed allocation,
that's why it's a good idea to
try to keep those pages full,
so that we have a small thing.
So the goal of most storage
allocators is therefore to use
as little virtual memory as
possible, and try to keep the
used portions very compact.
Because the more compact it is,
the more likely it is that
when you access one, you'll be
able to access something
nearby without causing
a page fault.
So that's the goal of almost
all storage allocators.
Try to keep things compact, try
to keep things tight and
in very little virtual memory
space, even though virtual
memory is huge.
Now, that doesn't mean that
everything has to be
contiguous.
For example, in this
organization as I showed
before, actually, I have it just
on the previous slide, so
why don't I go back there--
these are very far away in
memory, but there's only a
couple of them, and they're
tight and local in the regions
that they're operating in.
What I don't want to do is
have it where I have just
little stuff.
It's OK to go into the middle
of virtual memory and have a
whole bunch of consecutive
pages full of data.
That's fine.
What's bad is having just a
little bit of data, a little
bit of data, and a little
bit of data sort of
sprinkled all over.
That's bad.
But as long as I can put a whole
bunch of data nearby, it
doesn't matter where in virtual
memory I put it,
particularly.
So the idea is, let's try to use
as little virtual memory
as possible.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So how do we do that?
So the first thing is, binned
free list turns out to do a
really good job of using
relatively little memory.
So suppose that the user program
is using, at most, m
memory at any point during
the execution.
Maybe allocating,
maybe freeing.
But if I took the high watermark
of everything he
says that he needs,
we call that m.
Then it turns out that if you
use a bin free list allocator,
the amount of virtual memory
consumed is at
most m times log n.
Order m times log n.
And why is that?
Here's kind of a hand-wavy
proof sketch.
So whenever I make a request for
a block of size x, it may
consume at most twice x storage
that's actually in use.
And so it turns out that the
total amount of memory devoted
to blocks of size 2 to the k
is therefore at most 2m.
So for any given size, I might,
at any given point in
time, have the program using all
blocks of that given size.
Let's say size 2 to the k.
And since there are a
logarithmic number of those
bins, each bin of which could
have a size at most m, the
total is order m log m.
Now it turns out that there's
actually a stronger property.
In fact, you can show that
binned free list is order one
competitive.
Who knows the term "competitive"
in this sense?
The algorithmic meaning
of "competitive"?
So what it means is, it's at
most a constant factor slower
than the optimal omniscient
algorithm that could figure
out exactly what's going
on in every step.
So you're within a constant
factor competitive with the
optimal allocator, assuming
that the optimal allocator
does not do what's called
coalescing.
If it simply is dividing up
things, then it can subdivide,
but it can never glue things
back together again.
It turns out that in fact,
binned free list is really
much better than that.
So let's talk a bit about
coalescing, because many, many
memory allocators
use coalescing.
So the idea is, I'm concerned
about the case where I end up
with a whole bunch of little
small objects, and yet the
allocations now come
from big chunks.
And so I have to go and use more
of my virtual memory, or
maybe I can glue together those
little pieces into a big
chunk, and not have to
go off to memory.
So that's what coalescing
is all about.
So the idea is, if two things
are adjacent, let
me glue them together.
And there are really clever
systems for doing that,
including a very famous one
called the buddy system.
But using any of these
mechanisms for coalescing, you
always have to trade off between
the simplicity of not
coalescing.
Not coalescing so stick it in
the free list, I'm done.
Coalescing is, stick it in the
free list, oh, am I next to
somebody I can merge with?
Now let me merge.
So you always have to weigh, is
that really going to be an
advantageous thing?
It turns out there are no good
theoretical bounds that I'm
aware that prove the
effectiveness of coalescing.
People have not figured out how
to analyze this, or what
an appropriate model is for
understanding whether
coalescing is a good idea.
However, it does seem to work
in practice for some things,
and I think the reason for
that-- and this is just my own
take on it--
is that storage tends to be
deallocated as a stack.
So you tend to go into a region
of a program where you
do a lot of heap allocation--
let's say I'm building up a
graph, and I keep doing a
whole bunch of mallocs.
And when I'm done with the
graph, what do I do?
I free it all.
So I tend to have these batch
allocations and then
deallocations, and they tend
to work often as a stack,
often in a batch.
And that means that when I do
that freeing, I can sometimes
take advantage of that
and do coalescing.
In some systems, people have
what are called memory pools,
where you have a region where
when you allocate out of it,
you know you're allocating out
of your own particular region
specifically so that you can
do coalescing of things in
that region.
And so you may have multiple
allocators, and you'll call
the allocator on the region,
say, for a graph, because
let's imagine you're creating
two graphs, and one of them
you're going to keep around,
and the other
you're going to dump.
Well, if I create them at the
same time, the storage gets
all intermixed, I'll deallocate
one graph.
The other one will be, I'll have
fragmentation all over.
These little spots appeared
where the other
graph used to be--
not so good.
But if I say, use this allocator
for this graph, use
that allocator for that graph,
then when I'm done and I'm
allocating those out of two
different regions of memory,
that when I'm done with the
first graph and deallocate
everything, now I've created
a nice big piece
of contiguous storage.
So people will sometimes play
with different memory pools
for allocators, and C++ has a
fairly rich set of libraries
and so forth for that,
to allow you to do
that kind of thing.
So let's go on and talk about
garbage collection, because
that's something you've probably
seen in Java and
Python, and what's going on
under the covers there.
Because even though C and
C++ do not have garbage
collection, you can
actually implement
your own garbage collector.
It's not that hard, except
for some details.
It's only hard when you want
it to perform well.
So the idea is to free
the programmer
from freeing objects.
The downside, by the way, is
when you free the programmer
from freeing objects,
they tend to
create lots of garbage.
And so what happens in Java
programs, for example, is
you'll have these--
I remember once having a Java
program where, when it was
sitting, waiting for user input,
it would periodically
go, garbage collect.
It was just sitting
there, and then it
would go, garbage collect.
We weren't doing anything.
It was just periodically, the
way they had written the code,
they were somehow generating
garbage, doing allocations and
frees, when you were sitting
around doing nothing.
And so it would basically use
up all of the space and then
do a garbage collection, use
up all the space and do a
garbage collection.
Naturally that's kind
of a slow system.
And so even in something like
Java, where you have a garbage
collector, you do have to worry
about whether you're
creating garbage or not, and you
can generate faster code
by not creating as much garbage,
or by finding ways of
recycling the garbage
yourself.
So even in Java, it's worthwhile
saying, give me a
big chunk of memory, let
me manage it myself,
now let me free it.
I don't have to free it, but
when I'm done with it, I'll be
done with it.
But in the meantime, let me
manage it myself so that I
don't have it continually
generating more garbage.
So the garbage collector
can be built in, or
you can do it yourself.
And mostly in this class, we do
stuff ourselves, so we know
how they work.
So that even when you're doing
it with built in, you know
what's going on under
the covers.
So here's some terminology.
The roots in garbage collection
are the objects
that are directly accessible
by the program.
And those typically are things
like globals, stacked
variables, and so forth.
Things that the program can
directly address by name.
The live objects are reachable
from the roots by following
pointers, and the debt objects
are the ones that the
programmer can never
get to again.
And so what we're interested in
doing in garbage collection
is finding all the dead objects
and recycling them so
we can use them again, so that
they don't end up taking up
space in our virtual memory and
slowing us down by making
our virtual memory space
continue to grow and grow and
grow across many disk pages.
So one of the questions, in
order for one to be able to do
garbage collection, is
how do I know where
pointers are in objects?
How do I know what's
accessible?
And so typically, in order to
do that, you have to have a
very strong idea of where is a
pointer and where is data?
Because you don't want to
follow data as if it's a
pointer, you want to know which
regions of a given block
of memory are pointers.
And so strong typing helps a
lot with that, which is why
mostly people do garbage
collection in strongly typed
languages, because then you
can actually identify it.
It also requires you to prohibit
pointer arithmetic.
So the ability to take a pointer
and then index off
that pointer means I can get to
some piece of storage that
I can't access directly.
And so typically in these kinds
of systems, pointer
arithmetic is illegal.
So you can do array indexing, as
long as you treat the array
as a single object.
You can't treat an array as
the component pieces.
You have to treat it
as a single object.
So pointer arithmetic.
Well, you folks, who's
familiar with pointer
arithmetic?
At this point, almost all of
you have done stuff with
pointer arithmetic, if your
code is any good.
Almost all of you have done
adding to pointers in order to
move through an array or what
have you as being somewhat
cheaper than doing an array
index every time.
It saves you an extra memory
reference, typically.
So that's one of their
restrictions when you want to
do garbage collection in
a general setting.
Now probably the simplest
and most useful one as a
programmer to use for garbage
collection is what's called
reference counting.
I know many, many programs where
what you do is you do
reference counting
because you can.
But as you'll see, it
has a limitation.
So the idea in reference
counting is to keep a count of
the number of pointers
referencing each object.
So here we have a whole bunch
of different objects of
different sizes, and whenever
there's a pointer going to the
object, I add one to the
reference count shown in green
at the top here.
I hope I got the count right.
Whenever the count drops to
zero, you free the object.
That means nobody's pointing
to this object
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Let's free it.
So let's see how that goes.
So suppose that, for example,
that pointer got
moved to over here.
Went away from there,
got moved to there.
Well, now there are two fields
that have to be updated.
The one that we took the pointer
away from and the one
that we put it to.
So we update those.
Oops, that guy went to zero.
That means this stuff
is garbage.
But I can't just immediately
go and collect
that piece of storage.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: To save the value of
the pointer, and [INAUDIBLE]
pointer later?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, to save the
value of the pointer--
AUDIENCE: To save the value of
the pointer and then use it
again later.
The pointer isn't there,
but you know where--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Not
quite, not quite.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the reference counts for
[INAUDIBLE], and also--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
If you're going to deallocate
this guy, he's got pointers.
They have to follow his pointers
and see which ones
need to be deallocated.
Good.
So this guy now, we realize,
is garbage.
But before we can just free him,
I've got to deallocate
these pointers.
So this guy also got
decremented, but he didn't.
So this guy, we have to
decrement these two fields,
because we took away those
pointers because we're going
to garbage collect that.
And when we do that, it turns
out this thing turns to
garbage, as well.
So when you do reference
counting, you have to make
sure that when you decrement
things and decide you're going
to free something, you also then
go through and free the
things, and you continue that
process until everything that
has been deallocated
can be deallocated.
And then this becomes
recyclable, put back into the
storage, into your free list or
whatever scheme you have.
So this is a very simple way,
when you're implementing data
structures, of building your
own dynamic storage.
Because you basically can
allocate stuff, you can free
it, and whenever the reference
count goes to 0, boom.
You just have it deallocated.
OK?
But you can program that
yourself [INAUDIBLE].
Now there's a problem with
the scheme, though.
What's the problem?
Cycles.
Yeah, cycles are the problem
for reference counting.
So here's an example.
The problem is that a cycle is
never garbage collected.
Let's take a look at this
structure here.
So everybody's got a pointer
from somewhere, but it turns
out that there's a cycle here
where, notice that they are
pointing to each other, we even
have a guy coming off
here, but nothing points
into the cycle.
So there's no way that, from the
roots, I can ever access
these four guys.
They're garbage, but my
reference counting scheme will
never find it, because no one's
ever going to decrement
one of those counters here.
So those are all garbage,
but how would I know?
And that's basically
the disadvantage
of reference counting.
And uncollected garbage,
as we all know, stinks.
So we don't want that
situation to occur.
So nevertheless, reference
counting is great if you've
got an acyclic structure.
And the number of times acyclic
structures come up
where reference counting is the
simple and easy way to do
the storage management is huge
when you get into doing any
kind of interesting
programming.
Lots and lots of opportunity
to use
reference counting approach.
So questions about reference
counting?
You have a question?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this means you
actually have to do this
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
ever do a [INAUDIBLE]?
You can, like, save the work--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
That's right.
Whenever you move a pointer,
if you're going to move a
pointer, you first decrement
the counter on the place
you're moving it from, and then
garbage collect if need
be, and then you move
the pointer--
that's typically what you do--
you move the pointer and
increment the count at that
location, which typically
doesn't require any extra work
to decrement, which is the
trick thing.
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: There's no good way
to do this in idle time.
Like I'll have some idle time
later, let me do it--
CHARLES LEISERSON: So that's
what you use true garbage
collection for Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could actually,
there's techniques where you
can defer the work of
incrementing it.
Like you basically put the
increment and decrement
operations that you'd like to do
into a buffer, and then you
can do them later.
But it's sort of the same.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah,
you could log.
So there are schemes where you
log that, oh, I decremented
this, better check it
later, type thing.
Or I decrement it to 0.
Let me just put it in there,
and I'll go actually do the
stuff in batch mode at
some later time.
Yep.
So programming is fun, because
you can be clever with
schemes like that.
And that could be quite a
reasonable thing to do, which
is wait until you're waiting on
the user for input, and at
that point, collect
your garbage.
Now, the thing you have to risk
is, what happens if that
takes a long time
to get there?
And then there's the complexity
of your algorithms
and so forth.
So you get into a lot of issues
of software maintenance
and so forth.
But that can be a very effective
thing, is take it
out of the critical path of the
actual complication you're
doing, if that's mission
critical, and put it in some
part of the computation where
it isn't mission critical.
Very good idea.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: For thread safety.
Like if you have shared
reference accounts, like
multiple threads updating the
counts, you don't want to have
them all in the same count
at the same time.
So they fill it like a thread
local buffer, and--
CHARLES LEISERSON: I see
what you're saying.
Yes.
So we're going to get into
that as we deal with
multi-threading and so forth,
that if you've got two guys
that are operating on the same
data structure, you have to be
very careful about the
consistency, and that one
doesn't do something while the
other is doing something else,
and so forth.
So for that reason,
it can be a good
idea to postpone operation.
So general garbage collection
is based on a graph
abstraction.
So let's move into
the graph world.
So I can view objects and
pointers as forming a directed
graph G equals VE, where V are
the objects and E are the
pointers from one object
to another.
The live objects are reachable
from the roots.
And now the thing is that
finding all of the live
objects is then like doing
a graph search.
The common ways of doing a graph
search are depth for
search and breadth-first
search.
It turns out we're going to use
breadth-first search for
reasons that I'll show you.
So the idea in breadth-first
search, to
find all the objects.
So the idea is, what we're going
to do is go through and
find, where are all the objects
in my system that are
reachable from the root?
And then anything that
I didn't find, ah.
That must be garbage.
So here's the idea.
What we're going to use is FIFO
queue called Q. So that's
a first in, first out.
It has a head and a tail.
And the mechanism is very
much like a stack.
Whenever I need to enqueue
something, I put it on the
tail end and increment
the tail pointer.
Whenever I need to take
something off the queue, I
increment the head pointer.
So I'm always doing head and
tail, pushing on the tail and
pulling off the head.
Enqueue and dequeue.
So the way that this works is,
I basically go through all my
objects, and if they're a route,
I put a mark on it.
And I enqueue--
this is pseudocode, by the way,
so don't hold me to my C
programming standard here.
And I market, and then I enqueue
it on the queue Q. And
otherwise, I just simply
mark it as zero.
So being marked means whether
we've discovered it's
reachable from a route.
So to begin with, what we're
going to do is mark everything
that's reachable from the
routes, and we're going to
enqueue them on the FIFO.
And everything else, we're
going to mark as
unreachable, for now.
And now what we're going to do
is see which ones we discover.
So what we do is, while the
queue is non-empty, we're
going to take something off of
the queue and then look at all
of its neighbors.
So all the edges UV, look at all
the things that go from U
to V And if it's not marked,
then we're going to mark it
and put it on the queue.
That's it.
If it's already marked, we don't
have to do anything with
it, but if it's unmarked,
we'll mark it and do it.
And then in the end, everything
that's marked is
going to be something that is
live, and everything that is
unmarked is going to be
things that are dead.
But it's going to be actually
even sexier and more clever
than that, as you'll see.
So here's an example.
We start out with my queue being
empty, with head and
tail pointing to
the same place.
And what we do, is we go through
and we first-- in this
case, I have just one
route R, right here.
So we basically mark R
and put it on, and
that's how we get started.
And everything else is
unmarked up here.
So I'm going to mark with green
up here, and I'm going
to show what's on the queue with
the green down here, and
dark green when I pop
something off.
So the first thing I
do is I say, OK.
Let me dequeue something.
And in this case, I'm dequeueing
R, because it's the
only thing on there.
And what I do now is I visit
all the neighbors.
So I visit b, so I put that on,
mark it and put that on,
and then I visit c, so I
visit and put that on.
Then I'm done with R. I visited
all its neighbors.
So then I go and I dequeue
B, and now
visit all its neighbors.
Well, in [? visit ?] c, there's
nothing to be done
there, because c is
already marked.
So I don't enqueue it again.
I already have observed that.
And there's nothing else
adjacent to b, so basically, I
then go on and dequeue c.
So I have c here, and now we go
visit its neighbours, and
the neighbors are d and e.
So we enqueue d, enqueue e, and
now we are done dequeuing
all his neighbors and marking
them, so now we pop off d.
And now d has no neighbors, so
there's nothing to be done.
And now I dequeue e, and
basically, e has one neighbor
f, so we mark f.
Then we dequeue f, we mark g,
then we dequeue g, and g has--
the only neighbor is e.
And now my queue is empty,
and so I'm done.
And now you'll see,
what did I do?
I marked all the things that
were reachable from r, and
everything else is garbage.
Now, that's only
half the story.
So I've marked them, but more
relevantly, it turns out for
garbage collection, is look at
what I've got in my queue.
What do I have in my queue?
I've got all the live objects,
got put in the queue as we
were going along.
All the live objects are
put in the queue.
And not only that, but notice
they're all adjacent to each
other in the queue.
They're compact in the queue.
And so the idea is, we're going
to take advantage of
that property.
That when I do breadth-first
search, that the queue, when
I'm done, I put every
object in there.
So all the live vertices
are placed in
contiguous storage in queue.
So this is the principle behind
the copying garbage
collector, which is one of
the more popular garbage
collectors that's used.
The idea is that as I'm
executing, I'm going to have
some live objects and some dead
objects, and I'm going to
have some place that I'm doing
my next allocation at.
And as I go through, I allocate
more things in what's
called the from space, and I
keep allocating, and I may do
a deallocation, and maybe some
more allocation, and maybe
another deallocation, and some
more allocation, and
eventually I run out of my
memory that I've assigned for
my heap storage.
So when I get to this point, now
what I do is I'm going to
do breadth-first search
on the from space.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to copy using the
live storage here, using
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] to a TO
space, where the TO space
implements the FIFO queue.
So here's the TO space, and when
I go through and I walk
all that, I've now copied all
of the values, all of the
objects down to this
space over here.
And now I have this amount
of storage left.
I make the two space
exactly the same
size as the from space.
I have to make it at least that
big, because I know that
it may be that everything
here is alive.
Maybe nothing got deallocated.
So I have to make sure that the
TO space is large enough
to handle everything that might
be alive there, and it
may be everything.
So the TO space is generally
allocated to be exactly the
same size as the FROM space.
So basically, the way I
compacted is I copied things
down using the breadth-first
search algorithm.
Now there's one problem with
this, and that is that we have
pointers in these objects.
And when I copy it down here,
how did I make sure that all
the pointers now point
to the new locations?
So here's how you do that.
So since the FROM address of
the object is not generally
equal to the TO address,
pointers must be updated.
So I have to know, of course,
where the pointers are.
So the idea is that when an
object is copied to the TO
space, what we're going to do
in FROM space is store a
forwarding pointer in
FROM space saying,
I copy you to here.
So that whenever I look at
something in the FROM space
that's already been copied, I
can say, oh, here's where it's
been copied to.
It's been copied to this
region in the TO space.
When an object is removed from
the FIFO queue in the TO
space, we're going to update
all its pointers.
I'm going to give you
an example of this.
So if you think about it, when
I remove something from the
FIFO queue, at that point, I
know all of its adjacent
vertices have been placed into
the queue, into the TO space.
And so at that point, I know
where all the final
destinations of pointers are.
So here's an example.
So suppose that I'm doing the
copy of these guys, and I've
got all the pointers around
here, and now some of these
guys have already made it
into the FIFO queue.
Let's say this guy has made
it in, because I've got
forwarding pointer to there, and
this guy has made it in,
so I've got forwarding
pointer to there.
And this is what my queue
currently holds.
So when I remove an item from
the queue, I then look at this
guy, and what I do is first
of all, I visit all of the
adjacent neighbors.
So I visit this guy and I say,
oh, he's already been copied,
because I have a forwarding
pointer.
So nothing to be done there.
But this guy, he hasn't
been copied yet.
So I have to make sure that
that guy is copied by
enqueuing the adjacent
vertices.
So I copy my neighbor
to there.
And part of copying is, if I'm
actually making a copy, I'm
going to have a pointer
from here.
The pointer now has to point to
this guy over here, because
that's how I'm copying.
Otherwise it isn't a copy.
So in the copy, this pointer
is the same as that one, is
pointing to the same storage
location, namely
this place over here.
So I do that for all my
adjacent vertices.
People follow so far?
Now I've copied all of the
neighbors for this guy.
Now this guy, all of his
neighbors are in their final
destinations in the TO space.
So that means I can now update
these pointers to be the
pointers in the TO space.
So I do that as follows.
Oh, first of all, I forgot to
place the forwarding pointer
here to indicate that
he's been copied.
That's how I'm doing
the marks.
Sorry about that.
So I copied the values, and
that's just a straight copy,
because all the pointer
values are now
pointing into this space.
Then I put a forwarding
pointer in.
Now I'm ready to do the update
of the pointers here.
So I update the pointers
to the removed item.
So here's one pointer.
I get rid of him there and
I make him point to the
forwarding thing.
He used to point to here, now
he's pointing to here.
This one used to point to
here, I want to make
him point to there.
There we go.
So now he's pointing here.
And now this guy here now has
his pointers to his final
destinations.
And so the invariance that I'm
maintaining is that everything
before the head of the queue all
have their final pointers
in place in the TO space.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So do you know where
to put the pointers--
how do [UNINTELLIGIBLE] pointers
go from the TO space
to the TO space so that they're
actually getting to
their final destination?
So my question is,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] by following
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
But how do you know what
pointer to follow?
How do you know that
[INAUDIBLE]?
CHARLES LEISERSON: If I have a
pointer to something in the
FROM space, then I update it to
be the forwarding pointer
in the TO space.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the question
is, how do you know that
[INAUDIBLE]
it's being pointed
to [? the ?]
actually in the TO space?
Can you check, is this
in the TO space?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Well, yeah.
I mean, you know what the range
of the two spaces is, so
you could check that.
OK.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So the reason you
would be using [? BFS ?]
instead of [? DFS ?] is
because [INAUDIBLE].
CHARLES LEISERSON: The reason
you're using BFS is because it
has this nice property that
the queue represents the
copying of all the values.
If I use DFS, I need a stack
to do it, and then I'm
overwriting the locations where
the vertices would be
stored in the data structure.
By using DFS, there's this just
clever thing that the
queue, when I'm done with
DFS, represents all
of the visited vertices.
It's very clever.
Wish I'd thought of that.
But I was, I think, only 10
years old or something when
they invented this, and I
wasn't that precocious.
OK?
So very, very clever.
So this is the scheme behind
the Minsky, Fenichel,
Yochelson garbage collector.
So Marvin Minsky, you may have
heard of, was one of the
inventors of a scheme
like this.
One reason he's so famous.
Good.
So this is really nice, because
it takes me linear
time to copy and update
all of the vertices.
It's just one pass of
breadth-first search.
Very fast to copy and update
all the vertices.
Sometimes, by the way, people
call these forwarding
pointers, they call them
broken hearts.
You'll see that in
the literature.
They call them a broken
heart if it's--
I don't quite remember
why that's the--
it's like, I went there,
oh, you're not
there, it's over there--
it's like, I don't know.
Now, the last thing you have to
do-- and this is something
that's not talked about a
lot in the literature--
is how do you manage
these from and to
spaces in virtual memory?
So here's the strategy
that works well.
So basically, typically what I'm
doing is after I've done a
copy, I've emptied everything
out of the FROM space, and
I've got a portion that's used
in the TO space, and then an
unused portion that I'm going
to be able to do allocations
out of for the next
pass around.
So what I do at that point
is I make the old TO
become the new FROM.
So here's the new FROM.
This is available space.
And now what I do is I extend
this space, if necessary, to
make the new heap space that I'm
going to allocate out of
equal in size to
the used space.
And the reason for doing this
is to amortize the cost of
going through all of the
storage, so that the cost of
going the garbage question
can be amortized
against what's used.
If I didn't extend this, I might
have only freed up a
tiny little bit of space, and
now when I run out of that
space, I'll run the garbage
collector going over all the
elements, but I'll only have
gotten a few elements
[INAUDIBLE].
So what I want to do is make
sure that I've done at least a
certain number of allocations
proportional to the number
that I'm going to have to walk
over in order to finish it.
So that's why you make this
be the same size.
Now when the space runs out, the
new TO is allocated with
the same size as FROM.
So if you can allocate it back
in the old FROM space here,
that's great.
If there's room here
to allocate it
at the front, super.
That's where you allocate it.
But as in this example, the FROM
space here is bigger than
the space that goes
up to here.
So therefore what I do is I
allocate it at the end, and
then I go through and
copy to here.
Now if this ended up being
used, then the next time
around, I would be able to reuse
this space at the front
for the next time that I flip
the garbage collection.
The idea is, if things will
fit as early in memory as
possible, that's where
I put them.
But if they don't fit,
I put them later.
And you can prove, if you do
this, that the virtual memory
space used is order 1 times
the optimal, where you're
getting nearly the best virtual
memory space used
compared to the amount of items
that are in use by the
user at any time.
So it keeps everything sort
of compact towards
the front end here.
So in this case, I had
to allocate to here.
If the use had been very small,
I could have allocated
just a very small amount
for the heap.
When I was done, the
new TO space would
have fit at the beginning.
I would have allocated
it at the beginning.
And it's a nice little exercise,
for those of you who
are analytically inclined, to
figure out what the constant
is here, because it's a little
bit of a game to figure out
what the amortized constant,
for those who have some
algorithmic energy and our
confident about working in
this kind of thing instead
of studying for the quiz.
So dynamic storage allocation.
Hugely interesting area.
Lots is known and
lots is unknown.
For example, I mentioned
coalescing.
We really don't understand
Disaster people have been doing
it for 50 years or more.
We do not understand
coalescing.
There are a lot of strategies
that people have studied,
things like the buddy
system, I mentioned.
There are other types of garbage
collectors called mark
and sweep garbage collection.
Those are typically inferior
to the copying garbage
collection, because they
leave you with a
memory that isn't compact.
And so you end up using more
and more of your virtual
memory, because you're leaving
things in place.
On the other hand, you leave
things in place so there's no
need to move pointers.
So that can be a
valuable thing.
There's things called
generational garbage
collection.
Generational garbage collectors
realize that things
that are allocated typically
are freed very soon
thereafter, and so therefore, if
you especially take care of
the things that are allocated
and guess that they're going
to be used again, and that
things that haven't been
deallocated for a long time
are very unlikely to be
allocated, you can get better
performance out
of a garbage collector.
There's real time garbage
collection.
So this is what I've explained,
is what's called a
stop and copy garbage
collector.
Meaning that when you run
out of storage, oops!
Stop the world, run the
garbage collector.
There are real time garbage
collectors which, whenever you
do an allocation, it goes and
it does a few cycles of
garbage collection, and is such
that you can always keep
up with the allocations and
deallocations going on.
By doing a few cycles, you
eventually get to garbage
collect everything, but you do
it intermixed, so that you're
slowing everything down by a
constant amount, rather than
running and suddenly, OK, your
robot arm is going like this,
oops, garbage collect, garbage
collect, garbage collect,
[CREAKING SOUND].
So you can have your robot arm
move smoothly, because it's
paying the price all the way.
It's not stopping and going.
There is multi-threaded
storage allocation.
What happens when you have a
multi-threaded environment
where you have many processors
that are all allocating out of
the same pool?
How do they organize it?
You can have the interesting
things going there where
things are allocated on one
processor, and then get
deallocated on another.
And if you're not careful, you
have something like a memory
leak going on, which is called
memory drift, where the memory
gets allocated on one, and one
guy's busy creating it, and it
keeps getting deallocated on
the other, but never gets
recycled back to the
guy who needs it.
And so how is it that you figure
out to make sure that
memory drift doesn't end up
having you grow your memory?
In fact, many, many garbage
collectors that are out there
have this memory drift problem
for multi-threaded storage
allocation.
There's also parallel
garbage collection.
How do you, in a parallel
environment, have the garbage
collector going on as a separate
process while you
have other things going
on at the same time?
So a huge, huge, huge
area of storage.
And for our next lab, lab 3,
you'll be building your own
storage allocator.
So you have a lot of
fun with this.
[? Reid ?] says this is
his favorite lab.
Great.
Any questions?
OK.
Good luck on the
quiz next time.